[Music]
Bradley Cooper feeling the love from
fans and photons at the stars born
premiere in Spain on Saturday he also
flew solo without Lady Gaga for today's
Paris premiere the hype is so real for
this movie and as you'll see in this
exclusive behind-the-scenes look so is
[Music]
Bradley is an a visionary his
performance in this film is is out of
this world and I I loved singing with
him as well his voice is beautiful
[Music]
Bradley's raw and unbridled triple
threat performance is seen on full
display in this exclusive
behind-the-scenes footage you playing
guitar like a maniac okay I really don't
even think of it as me it really is
based on that character in preparation
for the role cooper spent five days a
week taking voice piano and guitar
lessons for six months straight
many of the songs in the film were
co-written and produced by Willie Nelson
son Lucas Nelson who's on a scale of 1
to 10 how do you think Bradley's playing
is on the guitar on the guitar I'd say
about a 5 or a 6 you know singing is
about a 10 for damn sure
yeah yeah because you know to do what he
did is impressive by anybody's standards
[Music]
[Applause]